I can remember growing up as a gamer my
friends and I would always talk about
the leap in graphics from one generation
to the next I mean anytime a new console
came out the first thing we always
talked about is can you believe how good
the graphics are now don't get me wrong
graphics alone don't make a video game
as we all know but it's almost always
the very first thing you notice right
the graphics the art style how it looks
and with Ratchet and Clank Rift apart I
really do feel like games have taken a
huge step forward particularly in this
animated Style
foreign
and while they're probably not quite on
the level of something like a Pixar film
just yet with Rift apart I do feel like
they are getting ridiculously close at
this point as you'll see here in this
video I mean even if you aren't A PS5
owner just as a fan of animation and
gaming I think even PC Gamers Xbox fans
will no doubt appreciate the absolutely
gorgeous visuals and just jaw-dropping
animation work from Insomniac here now
movies are always going to have an
inherent Advantage because filmmakers
are able to control every shot and sure
games can do this in cut scenes but
video game animators also have to
account for one crucial difference
between video games and movies and
that's of course us a player we have the
freedom to explore the world and analyze
nearly every single texture every detail
and then they need to have all of that
running at a smooth frame rate so the
actual gameplay is enjoyable so one
thing Rift apart really has going for it
is that it's one of the few games
developed from the ground up for PS5 and
only PS5 even other first party titles
such as Horizon forbidden West master
god of war Ragnarok while they look
fantastic they also have PS4 versions as
well so they weren't developed from the
ground up directly for the PS5 there are
a variety of different graphical modes
here in Ratchet and Clank and I ended up
going with the performance Ray tracing
mode on a 4K OLED television and let me
tell you even the performance mode looks
absolutely spectacular and I think to
fully appreciate this game you need a 4K
HDR TV to just appreciate everything
they've got going here now I'm not
saying it looks bad at 1080 but I did
try and capture some gameplay while
playing on a 1080 Monitor and while
everything looked good it just didn't
have that wow factor that I experienced
when playing it directly on the 4K TV so
the footage you're seeing here is 1080
but it's captured directly from my PS5
and depending on the size of screen that
you're watching it on if you're watching
it on a smaller screen it's probably
going to look great but if you're
watching it on a big TV or even a large
monitor don't let that fool you this
game in full 4K resolution is just so
nice my eight-year-old son has actually
been getting into this game a little bit
as well he saw me playing and thought it
looked so fun so he's tried it out a
little bit and we just keep talking
about I mean how it looks like a movie
of course being a parent we're a big fan
of Pixar here and again thinking about
all those inherent advantages that
movies have in terms of being able to
control the shot and the set frame rate
even with all of those considerations I
still especially in cutscenes I mean
Ratchet just comes insanely close the
reflections on Clank alone are
astounding I mean every time it showed
Clank at a cut scene I just could not
get over how glorious everything looked
reflecting off of him
okay
so you were being honest as I have been
saying repeatedly now I'm not a super
technical guy I don't know all the bells
and whistles and what's truly going on
here but I assume it is incredibly
difficult to do I know digital Foundry
has done a full breakdown on all the
graphical modes so if you really want to
get into the nitty-gritty there with all
the graphics highly recommend their
stuff as far as the frame rate goes for
me personally I found it to be a very
smooth experience with only the
occasional slowdown and that came during
some late game sections that were really
kind of intense sections of gameplay but
I would say 95 of the time the game felt
very smooth to me and again I was
playing on the performance Ray tracing
mode so I think it's pretty clear for me
the graphics are just absolutely
phenomenal but is rift apart purely a
visual showcase or is there more here to
make this title worth your time so I
just recently finished up my first
playthrough of the game and actually
even decided to go for the platinum
trophy and enjoyed every minute of it I
thought it was fantastic throughout I
have to say one of the common criticisms
that I've seen and kind of read online
for Rift apart is that it's just too
short and that makes me a little afraid
to admit that I beat the game over the
course of about four months now before
you immediately click away from the
video and say this guy is the Worst
Gamer I've ever seen or heard of it
wasn't four months of consistent play
typically it was an hour or two here and
there when I had time between being a
dad husband working my full-time job and
of course working on this YouTube
channel and as a kid or a teenager even
I probably would have totally just flew
through this game and been like oh that
was too short and honestly may have even
forgotten it a lot faster but the older
I've gotten and just given the fact that
I have less time to really put into
those long gaming sessions I've started
to appreciate more of these games that
are a much more contained experience and
games that have this kind of innate
approachability where you can jump out
and jump back in later without feeling
like you've just completely forgotten
how to play the game you're totally lost
in the story I think it's why I've
tended to gravitate more toward
multiplayer games in recent years
because I think you know they're so pick
up and play you can jump in at any time
but I have to say for Ratchet and Clank
Rift apart even as a single player game
I think one of the area is it really
shines is in just how approachable it is
even though I played it over the course
of months sometimes only having time to
play once a week I rarely ever felt like
I had to relearn something when I jump
back in there was this one particular
move with these kind of launch pads that
you find throughout the game I
completely forgot how to do that after
it had been a particularly long break
between sessions but that's the only
thing everything else was just
immediately familiar to me immediately
came back to me and it controls great
the mechanics and movement work well it
has a nice slick menu system and more
than anything it's just plain fun I mean
at the end of the day what I kept coming
back to with ratchet is just how
enjoyable it is to sit down and play the
game Traverse through the different
worlds searching for all the
Collectibles such as the gold bolts plus
all of the various weapon upgrades and
speaking of the weapons this has always
been kind of a staple of the ratchet
Series where they really shine as in all
of these zany bizarre over-the-top
weapons and most of them are pretty good
here there are a few that I never cared
for or really wanted to use much but I'd
say roughly three-fourths of them are
actually worth using or at least offer
some sort of fun element that make them
enjoyable to use and the game also makes
it super easy to control and switch
between the weapons you can map your
favorite 4 to the d-pad but most of the
time I found myself just going straight
to the weapon wheel all you have to do
is hold down the triangle you get the
full weapon wheel and at first you just
have one weapon wheel but the more you
go through the game and unlock more
weapons you end up having I think it's
like three weapon Wheels by the end so
at that point when you have that many
weapons it is kind of like an extra step
to page over but for the most part this
system just works really well now going
into this game one of the most talked
about features hyped up quite a bit by
Sony actually was this idea of being
able to transport immediately into other
dimensions using riffs hence of course
the name Ratchet and Clank ripped apart
now this was certainly visually
impressive and I can't imagine what all
it took under the hood to actually make
that work but overall it honestly didn't
have a huge impact on Gameplay at least
for me not as much as I was expecting
anyway I anticipated quite a few clever
puzzles and maybe some intriguing
gameplay scenarios taking advantage of
this kind of bouncing back and forth but
it really ends up being far more simple
than that it's almost just like you're
transported to another world for a bit
and then you jump back to the other
world I mean there are some times when
they use the dimension hopping mechanics
to have you start in one dimension then
you like hit a crystal transport to
another then you can reach an area that
you couldn't in the other dimension then
you progress there hit a crystal then
you're back in the other dimension that
sort of thing things that we've seen
before now to be fair there are some of
the more fast-paced sections with
Dimension hopping that I won't spoil
here I'm not even going to show them
because those are just absolutely
stunning visual I mean it's a visual
treat to see those but gameplay wise it
kind of just left me wanting a bit more
in that regard there are also a couple
of different puzzle type sections
throughout the game one features a
little Nano systems it bot named glitch
and another featuring Clank now for the
glitch sections I just did not care much
for these at all there's nothing really
bad about them they're just not as fun
as the core game and nothing really
Innovative about them I get there kind
of intended to be a change of pace but
it really just didn't work for me the
Clank puzzle sections on the other hand
though were great I found these often
struck that perfect balance between just
challenge enough to get you to have to
think a little bit but not so incredibly
difficult that you're just frustrated
and want to put the game down now one of
my favorite sections of the game are
these little challenges that you unlock
they take place in a battle arena on
what I think is the scar stew debris
field area these were pretty enjoyable
and some of them are actually quite
challenging and even required me several
attempts to beat they really forced you
to kind of stay on your toes during
combat and to take advantage of all the
different evasion mechanics that you
have in this game to really in some
cases keep from getting hit now one
little tip here I'll say if you're
struggling with any of these if you're
going for the platinum trophy or
something and you want to do everything
you can always come back to these after
you've leveled up certain weapons or
even your health a bit more there are
some for example that will require you
to just use one specific weapon and now
if you don't have that weapon upgraded
very high it's going to be even harder
but if you go back out Traverse the
other areas level up that weapon and
then come back it'll be much easier so
if you're ever looking for a more
challenging section that gives you a
break from the story then I would
definitely check these out now speaking
of the story though the characters in
Rift apart are fantastic mean the
Ratchet and Clank those two characters
for sure are iconic at this point you
already know them as the main two Heroes
but this game also introduces us to
rivet she is a lombax From Another
Dimension as well as kit now kit is
essentially clank's dimensional
counterpart and serves most of the same
gameplay functions as Clank but she does
have a few surprises in store as it
relates to the story and I'm not gonna
spoil those here for you so you will
play as both ratchet and rivet and
receive assistance from Clank and kit
throughout the game that's not a huge
spoiler there as far as the gameplay
between the different characters it's
exactly the same which I would expect
some will like and others may be
disappointed by personally I didn't mind
it too much I appreciated that I had all
the weapons and upgrades that I unlocked
no matter which character I was on I
would have access to all of them but in
terms of that differentiation sort of a
different feel between characters it's
just purely a visual difference and then
of course the different story segments
as well they are exactly the same to
control now while the characters are
great here the story in Rift apart is
just kind of there really I mean it's
not as basic as something like I don't
know the 3D Mario games but it's it's
pretty close to that level and honestly
does Ratchet and Clank need to have some
amazing incredible story no I don't
think so they could honestly stick with
the exact same formula they've been
using and be fine but if there was an
area they could look to improve I would
certainly add a better story to the list
we were talking about Pixar a bit in the
beginning and so while the game visually
is getting pretty close from a story
standpoint is far short of what you're
gonna find in a even Pixar's weaker
stories and as I was kind of writing
this video I think this is also an area
where the industry as a whole could
improve I mean if you think about most
of the amazing video game stories that
come to mind I don't know maybe just
because I'm older but the ones that come
to mind for me are more mature titles
there's like Red Dead Redemption Persona
the last of us there are so many of
those to count I mean too many to count
when it comes to more adult games but
I'd love to see some developers really
put some effort behind making a
top-notch Pixar level story from a more
family-friendly game series such as
ratchet I mean I've tried to sit here
right now and think of some good
examples of a family-friendly game with
a great story and honestly I'm
struggling most of the great family
friendly games are purely focused on
gameplay I mean maybe something like
undertale if you guys can think of any
let me know in the comments I'd love to
check them out with my sons so for me
ratchet and colleague is one of those
games I'd be fine playing once or twice
every new console generation updated
visuals updated weapons a new story The
Core mechanics they're just simply that
good they're plain fun and as games
continue to just grow bigger and bigger
and bigger and layer on all these
complex systems don't get me wrong I
love some of that stuff but at the end
of the day it's kind of a good reminder
to come back to just a traditional old
school video game and even though
ratchet is 3D and didn't come around
until the PS2 era I still think of it as
kind of an old school game at this point
now I do also have to admit there's part
of me that wonders if Insomniac really
wanted to take things to the next level
with ratchet like if they said hey let's
really level this up and go all out
there's nothing wrong with playing it
safe don't get me wrong I mean most
reviewers love drift apart it sold well
especially for a new system I personally
enjoyed it immensely all that being said
it's a series that would no doubt
benefit from a full open world treatment
it really would even more insane weapons
more Collectibles and even though it
wouldn't be at the top of my list I
would at least like to see them attempt
a more fleshed out story because again
the characters themselves are actually
quite good so is Ratchet and Clank worth
your time absolutely if you're a fan of
third person shooters action and a
family-friendly setting with lovable
characters I highly recommend it now if
you'd like to see a more extensive list
of PS5 games I'd recommend for families
and kids check out the video on the
right side of your screen now as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon